motivated by the death of Nightwing
Batman Begins as we said this is a new
water his detective case maybe there's
an even greater mystery that the Wayne's
murder was covering up and don't do it
because if you if you kill him we could
never be together weight cycles them
slash the Riddler's oh my god theory I'm
super excited to talk about the Batman
today did you guys see that there's a
photo that has a huge clue about what
the movie could be about because of a
potential working title we're also gonna
touch on the Suicide Squad
there also is a bird in the studio it is
anything can happen when a bird is in
the studio the bird is fighting me to
even talk I want to see a peck someone's
eyes out oh I wanted to oh yeah would be
very funny let's let's try to get the
bird in frame real quick I want to call
out that Erik's headshot is still in the
background because erik has been winning
rogue theory recently we will replace it
soon hopefully guys I with me this
episode our Erik the boss rustling hello
Tommy Bechtold so great to be so much
for having me and welcome back to Geoff
McCubbin welcome back welcome back
welcome back thank you two of us are old
alright did you guys see this set photo
yeah from the movie that may be referred
to as Batman vengeance may be at the
Batman it's a working title there was a
chair you know those fancy director's
chairs or actors chairs Eric has one
that says Eric on it
that's mr. Vassa it says Mr Bond for him
and he's done dirty things in it
structurally sound I neither see all
right so all right so this chair had the
working title on it vengeance
we're thinking well why would a Batman
film be called vengeance even as a
working title and that's what our rogue
theories are going to be about
today you guys are gonna tell me why the
Batman is going to be a story
specifically about vengeance alright
here's my road theory on vengeance we
have seen Batman in recent films break
his one rule in a way that not all fans
care award that's right this Batman will
wear white pants after Labor Day as much
as he wants while not killing anyone
either we're having Robert Pattinson as
the Batman I think we're gonna see him
get real close to that line just not
cross it but dangerously close to the
line in a way that's kind of freaky and
kind of scary we're talking torture
we're talking broken limbs he's gonna
waterboard ants he's gonna do a Robert
DeNiro stomp on someone's knuckles on
he's gonna curb stomping Robert DeNiro
does that well in the Irishman he did so
okay what if the vengeance is like a
true angry vengeance for the death of
his parents and when you and I are
working on an episode of big question
we're looking at the the emblem its new
emblem and a lot of people and I points
out and I break down to the teaser it
looks like it's made of parts that it
could be like a gun part like it looks
like two handles or the split handle of
a gun and one of the theories out there
is that this is Joe chills gun and that
we've seen that in comics before so what
if like this Batman takes vengeance for
his parents to a whole new level where
he is going as far as to torture members
of the crime families that maybe were
implicated in this murder of Gotham's
greatest philanthropists the Wayne
family and what if we we start this
Batman in Arkham Asylum year two what if
he got arrested for some of these
murders some of the crimes he's
committed what if this Batman the world
knows that Bruce man is Batman and
that's how like the way that Todd
Phillips made Joker something that was
really hard to ever try to put back into
a Cinematic Universe what if this Batman
is something that were it's gonna be
completely an elf's world universe where
everyone knows who Bruce Wayne is we we
know he's Batman and he gets out of
Arkham and now he's going back in he's
getting revenge
and he's just kind of detached from any
kind of moral code what said I think
that could be true because if you look
at the outfit I think you can see he
also is putting the pearls of his
mother's necklace that gets ripped the
thing that's interesting that you point
out aside from the theory I think I
think by the way that's my guess out of
the gate is sorry guys I'm already what
vengeance story is more prominent for
him than wanting vengeance for the
people that killed his parish or it's
driven him to do really insane things
like just like a bat but something else
that you just pointed out is his secret
identity is out and part of me is like
yeah wait a second who cares right he
doesn't it's not like oh my families now
his family is also bad vigilantes too
that are also regularly in danger
why does first friend Wayne really need
history yeah I think in the past it was
something that he did so we could hide
in plain sight that he could continue to
run enterprises and have access to the
weaponry that the company was building
whereas if you are a true vigilante you
can't even walk the street unless it's
at nighttime in your back it's very in
right now to have no secret I didn't
like spider-man got reveal Superman in
the comics just like man is the the
Batman equivalent in terms of the
billionaire who to use his own tech to
fight crime and was just like straight
up like yeah I'm Iron Man it's me and
then nothing changed about his life
really got to be Iron Man so maybe part
of Bruce Wayne's mission in this new
Batman story is to like to go after the
government and the infrastructure that
you know allowed Gotham to collapse
including like the new district attorney
that's gonna be played advice Peter
Sarsgaard who's so good at playing like
an [ __ ] like I feel like he's gonna
be the villain that Robert Pattinson's
going after mm-hmm so and so it's gonna
be a more ground level not supervillain
right yeah crime families yeah and and
just general murderers yeah like maybe
there's an even greater mystery that the
Wayne's murder was covering up like
maybe Thomas and Martha Wayne knew
something about like the crime families
their implication to the politics
that's why they were killed some people
are gonna fight you on that and be like
no it should be a random act of violence
because that's what happens in this town
but it can still be a random act of
violence and what happens in this town
and still you know indicative like why
is that guy running maybe you know maybe
they happen to see something in that
moment and he has to kill them for that
reason and he he actually he's gonna try
to kill Bruce too but Bruce runs over it
doesn't necessarily need to be a robbery
it can still without a beam like the
Wayne family actually has been at war
with the Joker family for decades
there's no like didn't have to be this
weird yeah and you know Joker reframed
the death of the Wayne's as like kind of
a random act of violence in a Joker riot
as opposed to someone trying to rob them
so I I think fans will be less Precious
about like the exact motive for why they
were killed but either way it's
reflection of the insanity and violence
of the city and I cool I like it and I
think it's gonna happen so you only get
one road view I think it's just so
likely yeah dang that's how this works
Tommy okay so here's let's get serious
guys this is all about vengeance and
it's not vengeance for his parents you
basic [ __ ] it's vengeance for
Nightwing Nightwing aka dick eg Dick
Grayson gray day every day is dead
Nightwing is dead so Nightwing so he's
an adult not an adult man a fully formed
adult you're not killing children's
using manscape razors on his body if you
keep it sleek keep it tight they didn't
pay for this episode we don't need to
shout that out sleek keep a knife
motivated by bang energy loves that
Jumanji card game which do you have a
deal did you watch it card again we
don't have a deal with the Jumanji card
I have a deal with everything Jumanji
okay Jumanji I got a piece of it anyway
motivated by the death of Nightwing
Batman Begins as we said this is a new
are his detective case he is the world's
greatest detective so we are going
around investigating we've got Paul Dano
as the Riddler I'm fairly certain we're
gonna investigate the Riddler we're
gonna investigate the penguin we're
gonna investigate
carmine Falcone I
soon there'll be other famous Batman if
not necessarily supervillains rogues for
him to question all leading to clues
about a mysterious killer that we find
out very similar to the VR game Arkham
Knight was actually this is a huge
spoiler for that game so if your games
been out for years
all the time I just know this is a big
spoiler for who the killer is in Arkham
BR and Tommy already forgot the killer
is checks notes Batman that's right
because there is a character in this
movie played by Peter skarsgård that's
gonna be an aggressive district attorney
but I think he might not be who he says
he is because I think when we do a
little dig deep dig er deeper digging
into who this character is it's none
other than dr. Jonathan crane aka
scarecrow okay who has a serum that can
make people pursue their worst
nightmares have have violent fantasies
and delusions and I believe that this
character who is then who is also going
to be investigating the murder of Dick
Grayson aka Nightwing is really just
creating the cover-up because he tricked
Batman into murdering Nightwing that is
my rogue theory and I rest my case was
he just in like a hallucinogenic raid
was he killed if we could share a roadie
for it I'm willing to push it towards
lover's quarrel
oh wow that you guys can hold this rogge
together for the rest of the segment
joint custody of ROG if you put it down
though you guys both lose Rogi or we can
cut it in half okay then you are the
true God we claim the weak link you of
the show oh no I'm for sure Tommy I love
it thanks I really liked the idea of a
detective story that has memento
elements - who hires Batman for this
Batman hires himself who usually when
the person who hires
Givaudan orcas usually ends up being the
guilty party or at least associate
because he dress up as like a bombshell
he's like I need your help
save me bet very cool so okay so in the
night wing has been murdered secretly
it's been by Batman but he's trying to
solve the murder of Nightwing and so
he's gonna what happens when he needs to
get the vengeance vengeance is against
himself so he commits himself to Arkham
the ultimate the ultimate final straw
for Batman is to stop himself from
stopping crime by stopping the most
dangerous person he knows which in this
case is him self Venn gone south
vengeance my favorite kind just a
masochist so then he locks himself away
and that's where we leave it this is
like Joker this movie exists in a
standalone piece and I understand that
that may I mean the reason this is a
rogue theory is because that's a tough
pill to get your DC comic fans to
swallow it's like we've made this epic
Batman movie and in the end it ends on a
kind of chilling note but if we're gonna
try something new and daring Joe
chilling note that's right no chill Joe
chill as I call him yeah I think you
know this one's gonna be a bit of a like
u downer well it's a bit of another Rogi
for you but you would have had it if you
had had five seconds of stamina I have
no integrity
I'm just so weighed down because my body
hasn't been scaped manscape i've skipped
your body and I appreciate that was a
great weekend great
so Geoff change our picture in our mind
right now - anything else
well I please why did we why did they
hire Robert Pattinson because he is hot
and has a huge fan base all those
Twilight ladies so they want to make
this a love story because we do know
that one Selena Kyle is going to be in
it
so picture this he's it like some kind
of
banquet event as Bruce Wayne he meets
Selina Kyle they're flirting he loves it
all The Riddler comes in holds it
hostage he can't do anything because
he's Batman and then she gets thrown out
of the building kind of her origin story
and so now he is on vengeance to figure
out quick important detail yes just not
on the first floor the big this banquet
is on the penthouse of the highest
building in costume okay
[Laughter]
plummets down to her supposed death so
this is about him trying to get
vengeance against the Riddler but every
time he gets close the evidence gets
stolen away by some new burglar on the
beat so now he's like yeah I have to
find this burglar who's trying to beat
me to the punch with the Riddler and get
the Riddler and then spoiler it turns
out this other burglar is none other
than the Catwoman because she wants to
get revenge on the Riddler but the same
time they've like fallen in love so at
that pivotal moment you know he's just
like she has the Riddler and she has
like I don't know a knife to his throat
a gun to his head something he's like
dating Joyce yes kitty claws like and
he's like don't do it because if you if
you kill him we can never be together
cycles them slash the Riddler's - oh my
god like hot - I think it's because he
started to whisper oh wait try
whispering something no matter what you
say is hot as hell if it's whisper so he
is trying to solve a murder that didn't
take place exactly he looks like yeah
but he and you just want some vengeance
cuz he hit it off one night with maybe
they were dating for a while
we need to have one zoe kravitz Robert
Pattinson sex scene yeah and I think it
should be hardcore just the DVD release
you buy the tube to tape VHS you get a
full penetration tables in the scene but
we're not saying what just watching Jeff
you get Al Rogi and then you get an
additional Rogi because that theory was
worth two hottest fell druggies and then
also the still have the road game
earlier from being a nice daddy
yeah well done guys come back to me in a
tweet need to find out who night wings
killer is look in the mirror and you'll
see clearer , Batman flower Friday
Batman
poison ivy Catwoman mr. freeze
Commissioner Gordon Vicky Vale Nightwing
Robin that's the only one doesn't add in
concepts she might be dead
call her quick okay my tweet is Batman's
vengeance is to avenge his parents who
were actually killed as part of a
conspiracy between the Maroni and the
Falcone crime families which goes all
the way to the top baby a thread one -
second tweet bad puns and finally we
find out that Peter Sarsgaard is
actually the man who pulled the trigger
well done yeah and Jack riddle me this
great love that alright yes riddle me
this what's more dangerous than
vengeance whispered it again
I'm very intrigued actually you guys did
a decent job because I would watch all
of these movies because Batman doing a
detective story that's more does need to
be this kind of thing and I'm feeling it
I'm not loving what Tommy's doing with
his eyebrows but that's fine it's
unrelated yeah he doesn't even know he's
doing it so guys great job on those I
want to hear your theories in the second
about Suicide Squad because we also got
a little bit of news about that and
we're staying on a DC kick but first
real quick just Eric tell them what
we're doing this week for a big question
you already kind of did a little bit
yeah we've been working on this whole
idea of the Batsuit right there's
there's this new Batsuit there's this
test footage mock-up so we were able to
put a put together that shows what it
probably actually looks like if you fill
in the above nipple gap and write years
even yeah and a lot of you guys been
tweeting this about this emblem asking
like how is it changed cuz it looks
different and of course they do that
with every new iteration of Batman but
this one looks like it can be removed
and turn and weaponized so like I'm
Phillip and I are currently working
neither of us are seeing what each other
working on but we're currently working
on like we're trying to reconstruct this
emblem to see what kind of weapon it
could be and see how effective it would
be in hand-to-hand combat and I'm really
excited to see like what you've come up
with
because right now mine's kind of a mess
so so watch that episode a big question
please if we really like it let's go to
move on to Suicide Squad okay so there
was a set photo that was released we
don't know much about this movie we just
know that James Gunn is completely maybe
even disconnecting it from the first
Suicide Squad but it's also he was like
no it's not just gonna be guardians of
the galaxy so we know it's gonna be
still in the vein of the darkness of the
Suicide Squad not not toned but rather
people died right unlike guardians
mostly so the one thing that we can add
to this story now is that we've seen
that for some reason the squad goes to
South America and I do the way you guys
nodded makes em feel like you guys are
not sure what that is okay explain to me
real quick so not southern America so
okay so there's America which is the
greatest country in the world and then
there's hat there's there's a candidate
hat
it's called hat let's called hat hat and
they're going down to boots is boots
Central America or Mexico or all the way
there's a Central Dorothy's forehead
zoot suits great and then Jeff how do
you want to insult my people and by your
people you mean youtubers right we don't
know where exactly in South America but
there are theories that it might be
Brazil okay yes so I go ahead and pitch
me why the squad is going as they say
down under South America the same
continent um we do know that Benicio del
Toro is playing a character named the
general or the mayor it's it's a named
yet but what if like it's gonna be kind
of like a narcos situation or even
better Fast Five the best of the past
series where they have to go to Brazil
and there's this like warlord drug lord
basically who has taken over a town and
they they have a heist they drag a safe
through the streets of the city it's
amazing imagine like the Suicide Squad
being sent by the US government but the
US government cannot sanction they can't
send like SEAL Team six in there they
have to use these like squad of
criminals to take out this drug lord
because he's like too powerful he's got
access to some kind of new thing maybe
in this case like granted not everyone
was crazy in the first Suicide Squad
about the whole in tranche for his
storyline where she goes to Peru and she
goes in this cave and that's where you
know she ends up becoming in chant
rest's what if there's like some other
kind of like relic or talisman from that
cave that also Toro has gotten access to
and he has to be stopped so they send in
the Suicide Squad but now it's James
Gunn who's in control of it so he's kind
of making fun of the first one a little
bit of how goofy this this mysticism was
but now he's applying his kind of sense
of humor to it and they're addressing
past suicide squads but this one's kind
of like we got to deal with this again
but now it's in the hands of Benicio del
Toro a drug lord who's like taken over
the small town potentially all of Brazil
yeah what's very cool so you're so
you're taking Dirty Dozen GRE which you
know Suicide Squad is kind of based off
of right but something that the
government's like well we don't really
care about these people so we can send
them
my mission but you're kind of combining
with heart of darkness and Apocalypse
Now
oh sure this idea of like the Colonel
Kurtz character that is like somewhere
deep in the jungle theoretically
whatever and has created like maybe a
whole compound that is not even
penetrable right and then they have to
go in and take him out except you add to
Colonel Kurtz now some sort of talisman
is giving him insane power she actually
has powers instead of he's just gone
delusional right okay all right I'm
feeling it
the amount of full quarter okay all
right yeah but it's straightforward but
I like it yeah yeah DOMA all right my
theory and I'm actually I'm pretty proud
of this one I think that the the gang's
back to look it's not a sequel we know
but there are a lot of similar actors so
your are actors from the first movie
that are reprising their roles so I
think it's gonna be impossible to truly
separate them but I don't think that is
as important to the central plot as as
it may seem they're gonna discover that
there's a compound or a factory setting
up that is mining precious metals and
and energy sources in South America with
this unknown power source that is
allowing them to ramp up production just
basically destroy the ecosystem of where
they are and they need to send the
suicide squad down to stop this stop
stop them from just mining into the
earth and destroying and creating all of
these climate problems when they get
there they discover that Benicio Del
Toro's character has somehow through
some technology maybe a Lex Luthor like
scientist or someone with genius
intellect has and maybe Benicio del Toro
is playing a character from comical
Canyon that does have like a science
background has has captured Hal Jordan
in the Green Lantern mmm and has him in
a medically-induced coma where they are
stimulating his brain to synthetically
creator or artificially create the
impulse to create power with his Green
Lantern ring so they're basically mind
controlling Hal Jordan to manifest his
will as a power source and that's what's
allowing them to create these super
drills and super harvesters that are
basically destroying this this this this
ecosystem of this country in South
America so there you go in to get to
basically unplug Hal Jordan
and you know Killa no I think he'll be
the green lantern then this also could
be a way to kind of back channel in some
DC Cinematic Universe characters like
whoever the new Green Lantern is gonna
be or maybe it is the death of Hal
Jordan which gives us Jon Stewart or
something like that
awesome yeah you could backdoor Jon
Stewart I would love to backdoor Jon
Stewart
both the Valerius Lantern and the
comedian but uh maybe Jon Stewart we we
don't know who John Stewart is but maybe
there's you know soldiers that are
helping that are assisting the Suicide
Squad with Rick Flagg with Joel Kinnaman
his character and maybe one of them is
Jon Stewart you know and so he gets the
ring maybe Hal Jordan does die maybe he
is dead you know all but brain-dead
except for that you know what they're
using them for and then when they unplug
him off of the machine that is you know
using him as a power source Jon Stewart
gets the ring and becomes a new Green
Lantern and then that leads us to a
Green Lantern movie do we know who
either saw was playing I don't think
officially there's a lot of rumors that
he's playing vigilante which we've seen
in arrow yeah they've used on TV they
use that character an arrow but that was
kind of I don't know just throw out
there that you know you could have a Jon
Stewart there yes absolutely can I throw
in a pitch of a scene I'm hearing all
pictures yes yes I can at one point
Harley Quinn get the ring
so that she can turn Courtney's got to
get it for a second throw a massive
green boomerang yeah I think yes that
pitch is accepted and integrated as they
say in key and Peele it's going in the
movie
I also reminds me a little bit is it in
flashpoint where Superman is held kind
of like for his whole life against as
well yeah yeah yeah and then he becomes
this little disgusting weakling yeah
yeah so but doing that with Green
Lantern very cool Tommy you get a full
quarter oogie ranks and then Jeff what
do you got
why are they in South America mine's a
little far-fetched but there we go work
with me here all right a bunch of
celebrities are in Brazil - like
protests this new area that's being like
good the rainforest is going to be
demolished but then this militia has
taken over and taken them all hostage
but because Republicans are in power
they don't care about these dumb
liberals so amanda waller is being
funded by the Liberals to save the Soros
and the head celebrity that's down there
that's been kidnapped is Pete Davidson
he is going to blame himself in the
movie and then immediately I'm like
people are sacrificing themselves for
Pete Davidson what's for the money but
when they get down there it turns out
the twist is it is actually they're not
there to save the celebrities all the
celebrities get mowed down immediately
it's actually Lex Luthor who's being
held hostage and they are actually the
militia people are actually good guys
trying to stop Lex Luthor from mining a
kryptonite meteor right yeah and just
remember Pete Davidson gets brutally
murdered in this movie what do you have
a get are you team a loriana
oh yeah that's a full-blown rogue gear
yeah
very solid I want to hear him again you
know maybe like a little bit of a tweet
for sure Suicide Squad is narcos meets
Fast Five with Benicio del Toro as a
drug lord the small South American town
who needs to be taken down yes okay ah
lanterns of green yeah you know what I
mean just wasted so many characters
unplugging Hal Jordan and maybe meeting
Commissioner Gordon Suicide Squad a
backdoor to the DC Cinematic Universe of
course that's the twist
what's the environments last hope Oh
[Laughter]
safe environment essentially Lex Luthor
right yeah
billionaire I think that's the look he's
going and I'm out of normal thanks get
somebody else how about this
alright these rookies each represent the
Suicide Squad in South America
and whoever most quickly can come up
with ways that the Suicide Squad goes
out gets a member of The Suicide Squad
so just start shouting out how a Suicide
Squad remember Captain Boomerang koala
bear syphilis that's one for Harley
Quinn sniffs the wrong thing just missed
something bad Killer Croc a Florida gift
shops at harvest crocodile to you too
much rhyming rick flagg he just gets a
paper cut infected oh no froggy I'm
Idris Elba it says something offensive
gets cancelled and yah blow riding the
Maid of the Mist of Niagara Falls and
having the water put out his fire it's
just so dream you know you lose both of
those two rules of the game all right
let's recap where do these rogue is at
three why but I trust Eric a lot so
you're at four because that's what Eric
said you had all right and guys it's
time for rogue questions great alright
this could change everything in ways
that don't matter all right guys
Harrison Ford said in an interview that
this week that he doesn't know what a
force ghost is explained force goes to
Harrison Ford in a way that he'll
understand have you ever wanted to see
your grandpa again because he was so
kind if he was good enough you'd be able
to
as a ghost he could talk to you but he
must have up some other way in his real
life cuz he ain't a rogue a force ghost
he's just a regular ghost self-censor
hey you know how that like voice of
Calista Flockhart is always nagging at
you imagine if it was in hologram form
that's a force when someone dies when
someone dies Harrison Ford they go to
heaven but what if God told them get off
my plane of existence he only
understands his own movie quotes it's a
roadie for Eric alright
leaked footage from the set of venom 2
shows Woody Harrelson's carnage has got
this a different haircut than in the
venom one end credits scene what what
incredible in-universe explanation do we
have for this in undescribable hair
change so spider-man webbed up his hair
his curly Sideshow Bob hair and because
his webbing dissolves after an hour it's
like the perfect conditioner it just
dissolves into his hair follicles and
made it straight oh I think that electro
came in and kind of tried to give him a
hug but there was a puddle and so the
current of electricity went through
carnage and electrocuted his hair I
think you know it just
he saw his mail or any God it was a
discount coupon for super cuts yeah I
like simple explanation the best
superhero super super coupon yeah guys
and the pot of the upcoming Bill and Ted
sequel came out this week and in it the
two heroes have 90 minutes to write the
best song ever I'm not gonna give you 90
seconds to come up with the best song
ever and we'll go ahead and cut to 90
seconds from now
now several bad puns later
do-do-do-do-do-do bill and ted do plan
to fill in Ted to the best of friends
drill at Ted on a roller coaster to Bill
and Ted conquers a coaster to Phil
intend to on tinder 2010 to in a blender
to mix them up do George Carlin so
impressive it just kept going and it
kept changing and it kept flowing and he
didn't even take any breaths that's a
full other Rogi for Jeff it was he
really was the strongest that's gotta be
a high score of roadies alright let's
get our our final point totals I have
four roadies and my worst showing ever
on the show I have to Jeff do you want
to give any of your oh geez to anyone
else
oh my god everyone George Bailey Ville
of roadies oh oh captain
alright in the highest point total yet
1212 rogue ease for Jeff give it up for
Jack Jeff if you can submit a headshot
we will put it on on the back there and
then Tommy's wish on one day
Eric's wish and Jeff's wish Eric must
look into the camera and confess his
love of Lucky Charms cereal in his best
Harley Quinn accent oh I love Lucky
Charms cereal the horseshoes the clovers
the blue moans they all taste great but
not as great as mr. J it was like a
perfect ad for Lucky Charms until it got
even better
it's not milk all right guys
you can file your complaints with these
people individually on their social
media Eric where can we find you a TA
vas everywhere and on this channel
obviously we got some great videos
coming out this weekend we're gonna be
talk about Clone Wars guys it's back and
and yeah we have this really great
episode a big question that I'm very
excited to hear your answers on how this
suit is engineered case it it's really
crazy Tommy at Tommy Beck told Tommy -
back told somebody gonna send you a
request for six thousand dollars have it
because I'm rich you can follow me at
evil Jeff on Instagram or the podcast I
host comic-book queers at Comic Book
queers I thought it was Queens took
weights and then follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at Phillip Malina thank you
so much for watching and make sure to
get this as a podcast Tommy's getting
really ready to clap so if everyone just
kids ready for Tommy to clap he will end
the episode and this will be it for us
good bye to everyone and Tommy is almost
ready
he's almost warm here it is about to
[Music]